cette stratégie ce mode opératoire des
troupes russes on va tenter de le
comprendre de l'analyser avec vous
alexandre jublin bonjour à vous sept
producteurs de collimateur c'est un
podcast d'analysé militaire et
stratégique de lindsay remercie d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de france 24 depuis
le début de cette invasion russe le 24
février dernier on a vu les soldats se
positionner sur différents froid dans le
nord dans l'est et dans le sud du pays
mais là avec la frappe de ses bases
militaires d'oeil à voreppe dans l'ouest
du pays on a l'impression finalement que
la stratégie est en train de changer
qu'est ce qui est en train de se passer
selon vous
ils essayent de taper là où ils peuvent
les russes alors c'est les bombardements
et les frappes de l'emporter sont pas
nouvelles ils en ont déjà fait après il
faut qu'ils gèrent avec des stocks qui
seront probablement limités ils peuvent
pas faire ça éternellement la la rigueur
et vos conseils ils ont des cars est
déjà hier que les convois notamment
d'armes qui sont amenés par les forces
occidentales aux troupes craignait ne
pouvait devenir une cible et on sait que
cette base était un centre
d'entraînement dans le passé maintenant
depuis le début de l'invasion c'est
évidemment beaucoup plus compliqué et
certains instructeurs étrangers s'ils
s'y trouvaient on sait pas c'est
compliqué en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que les américains sont partis
depuis un certain temps c'est une baisse
qui avait l'avantagé d'être pas loin de
la frontière polonaise donc ça
permettait pour les troupes de l'otan
qui était éventuellement stationnés en
pologne devenir juste faire des missions
la bond à la rigueur c'est déjà c'est
une cible militaire ce qui est en ce
moment est déjà pas si mal pour les
russes parce que quand on voit ce qui se
passe à marioupol ou ailleurs déjà
augmente pour une fois ils ont tapé une
cible militaire mais on sait que c'était
aussi un point d'acheminement
probablement de l'aide militaire
occidentale avant de la redistribuer aux
unités ukrainienne donc bon clairement
il semble que les russes cherchent à
couper les lignes d'approvisionnement
chercha à frapper dit dans les convois
qui permettent de renforcer les forces
ukrainienne ça fait probablement partie
d'iron de cette philosophie qui est bon
les russes peuvent se projeter là dedans
en ce moment et c'est qu'ils sont en
train de faire j'aimerais vous faire
réagir avec déclarations du ministre
français des affaires étrangères qui se
disaient pessimistes quant à la suite de
ce conflit une guerre qui risque de
s'installer une logique de deux sièges
autour de kiev on va écouter jean yves
le drian on en reparle juste après
on ne peut pas discuter de quoi que ce
soit avec un revolver sur la tempe le
préalable de tout c'est d'ailleurs ce
que emmanuel macron a demandé hier avec
beaucoup d'insistance au président
poutine si le cessez-le-feu pour qu'on
puisse discuter
or là nous sommes devant un mur une
logique de sièges qui risque de durer
longtemps si bien que devant cette
situation je pense que le pire est
encore devant nous ça veut bien vous
êtes quand même très pessimiste matin
oui
je suis pessimiste parce que à un moment
donné on a pu croire qu'il y avait
quelques petits espaces et les petits
espaces semble se refermer avec le
renforcement des actions militaires et
avec le blocage des discussions le pire
est devant nous c'est aussi votre
sentiment alexandre jous je sais pas le
6 et le pied en tout cas il est certain
que ce n'est pas terminée ne serait ce
que parce qu'il ya un intérêt bien
compris c'est à dire le plan ou c'est
maintenant c'est qu'il y avait il ya un
geek en quelque sorte de partie à cette
invasion de l'ukraine y avait un premier
plan qui était de décapiter complètement
l'état ukrainien avec l'espoir que tout
tombe d'un coup ça ça a raté maintenant
on est dans une campagne beaucoup plus
méthodique beaucoup plus progressive
beaucoup plus lente beaucoup plus
meurtrière aussi bons les prendra le
temps que ça prendra mais vladimir
poutine ira jusqu'au bout c'est la chute
de litres est
probablement en tout cas il peut pas
s'arrêter sur un échec et ce qui est
certain c'est que les forces sont en la
faveur des russes il ya un écart de
force qui est énorme en faveur des
russes et des ukrainiens résiste
extrêmement bien en contrôlant le
terrain etc mais plus le temps passe et
plus ce décalage de force s'accentuent
notamment parce que les russes peuvent
atténuer effacer un peu notamment les
problèmes d'organisation et logistique
qu'ils auraient eu à un moment si on
prend le temps de se réorganiser de
mettre en place des lignes logistiques
et cetera on peut atténuer un peu des
problèmes d'organisation que on a vu que
les russes avaient au début donc le
temps je vous pourrez en quelque sorte
si du taur tech qui réussissent disons à
aplanir leurs difficultés du début donc
effectivement une asymétrie évidente
dans cette guerre les équipements ne
sont pas les mêmes mais tout de même les
les russes se retrouvent face à une
résistance acharnée de la part de
l'armée régulière ukrainien huit civils
aussi qu'ils se sont engagés à ce que
les russes aussi sont plus performants
qu'elle se fait essentiellement par le
ciel cette guerre est ce qu'une fois les
troupes déployées au sol ou peut-être
des combats au sol vous vous me corriger
si je me trompe mais là cela donne sera
différente
les troupes russes sont déjà bien
déployées au sol et ils ont des
problèmes avec ça oui
cela dit les russes ont des problèmes
dans le ciel aussi depuis le début ils
ont échoué à supprimer les défenses
antiaériennes ukrainienne au tout début
et ça ça d en disposer l'équilibré des
forces parce que ça fait que les avions
russes peuvent pas circuler librement
dans le ciel donc ça c'est extrêmement
important pour eux ça limite leurs
marges d'action bon c'est il faut voir
ce que ça donne il est certain que le ya
une très grande dissymétrie interne
d'aviation mais l'aviation ukrainienne
vole encore et ça c'est déjà en soi à la
fois un symbole et une performance tout
à fait étonnant c'est ce qu'on appelle
un espace aérien de contester ce que peu
de gens anticipaient à plus de deux
semaines du début du conflit personne ne
pensait que les ukrainiens seraient
capables de rendre de mettre en
difficulté les russes et ça explique
beaucoup de choses puisqu'on sait que
mon les russes autant dans leur
entraînement que surtout dans leurs
déploiements précédente soit en géorgie
en ukraine en syrie ils sont
traditionnellement m désert et
probablement que c'est dans ce logiciel
là qu'ils étaient partis qui étaient
dans ce logiciel là qu'ils pensaient
opérer et faute de cette maîtrise des
airs ben on voit que tout se complique
sur le terrain effectivement déjà
maintenant puis ensuite évidemment plus
vont prendre de terrain puis ça va être
compliqué c'est sûr il ya une crainte
depuis quelques jours depuis peut-être
48 heures voire plus maintenant
alexandre jus blanc sur une éventuelle
attaque chimique russe et américain
s'accusent mutuellement est ce que vous
pensez qu'on peut en arriver là est ce
que cette ligne là peut être franchie
non c'est fin c'est douteux savon on
sait par les russes n'ont pas utilisé
d'armes chimiques enfin ils ont soutenu
le régime de bachar al assad qui faisait
des attaques chimiques ne sait pas
exactement la même chose
ce qui est probable c'est qu'il ya une
tentative de rééquilibrer dix ans le
poids moral de dans cette guerre c'est à
dire cette idée que les russes voudrait
être aussi dans la dénonciation puisque
jusqu'à présent la guerre de l'opinion
la guerre de l'information de la guerre
de l'image ils l'ont perdu
incontestablement à peu près partout
donc c'est probablement une tentative
d'équilibrer un peu la balance de ce
point de vue là après il y est pour tout
ce qui est russie a toujours plusieurs
publics il ya un public international ça
on voit que ça prend très peu voire pas
du tout notamment à l'assemblée j'ai au
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
puis il ya un public aussi domestique et
sa vue qui maîtrise des canaux
d'information peut-être que ça prend
plus sur la scène politique enfin sur la
scène domestique russe c'est dur à
savoir depuis paraît qu'il est maîtrisé
qui les verrouille m merci beaucoup
alexandre merci merci pour ces éléments
de compréhension